-And finally, guys,
it's Tuesday.
It's time for "WeTweet,"
here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Now welcome --
welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going
to vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats? Very good.
Now you can -- you can vote
for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
We will see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have your clickers?
-Got it.
-Yes, we do.
-Good. Alright.
Now, whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we'll tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
[ Cheering ]
It's a shared experience.
Okay, are you guys ready
for this?
Our first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
I have an idea.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-I can tell --
I can tell just --
even with the masks on,
I can tell how disappointed
the audience is.
I can feel it.
-They're tragically delicious.
-Do you think
100 percent no on this?
-I'm going to say 80 percent no.
-Yeah I'm gonna go a little
higher, 95 percent no.
-95 percent no?
-I know one person
that voted yes.
-Voted yes?
-Yeah.
-Oh, you're being nice.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
Boing.
There you go.
Alright, no problem.
We have four more.
-We got four more.
-We got four more. Here we go.
-That was just a test run.
[ Laughter ]
Tepid.
-You don't have to --
you don't have to aim
the clickers at me,
by the way.
[ Laughter ]
I saw some -- some gentleman's
out there...
-Change.
-Don't get mad at me.
I have nothing to do with it.
-Change.
That doesn't help
or hurt the results.
-He's trying to change the joke.
-I don't know if that's -- that
one's going to win either.
Let's see the results
on that one.
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah, not good.
Yeah, these are not great.
Alright, here we go.
How about -- let's try
this next one here?
Here we go.
This one...
[ Laughter ]
I feel like that --
I feel good about that one
-Well, out of the three, yeah.
-I think we feel good
about that one.
-That one's through the roof.
-Right, that one's --
you think a hundy?
-Not a hundy, but close.
I feel like you
starved them out first,
so now, you know,
they're hungry.
-I'm going to say 144.
-I didn't do it on purpose,
by the way.
I'm just reading the tweets,
and they just happen
to be in this order, yeah.
-Okay.
-They don't get better
necessarily.
[ Laughter ]
Just so you know.
If you haven't --
Anyway, let's see the results.
-144.
-Whoa!
-177.
[ Applause ]
-Wow! 177.
-I knew that
was going to be a good one.
Alright. we have --
Is this our last one?
-No, two more.
-Two more.
-Alright, good.
You have two more.
If you haven't started
playing, now --
[ Laughter ]
Alright, how about
this one here.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Yeah, it's like --
yeah, that's -- yeah.
What do you -- what result
are you not getting, sir?
[ Laughter ]
You're not going to see
any result by pointing it
at anything or aiming it at me.
Nothing comes on the screen
until we're ready.
So, just have fun, relax.
-Beep.
-We're all on is this ride
together.
Here we go.
Let's see the results
on this one.
Yeah, that figures.
Alright, I got you.
Alright.
This is the last one here.
This is your last time.
I think pigs are going to be
the one that's going to win.
-Yeah, but this one --
-But this one's
pretty good, too.
This is the last one
here for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
The last one is...
[ Laughter ]
-I like that one.
-Yeah.
-By far.
-By far the best kids game?
-By far the best kids game.
-By far out of all
of the kids game.
-Out of all of the naked
operation games...
-That's correct.
-Operation is by far --
-That's right, by far.
Alright.
-Unless you're playing with a
leprechaun.
-Time to see the results.
Here they are.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No! No! No!
The winner by one
is pig relationships.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow, that's fantastic.
I will post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like.
Give it a "WeTweet" and enjoy.